[Musique]
avant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
tu as vu mon bracelet et regarder
comment ça s'est abîmé
j'ai pris l'habitude de porter un
bracelet je crois que je m'en faire
faire un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui pourrait me faire seul
ah oui tiens
bonne idée il fonce hermès je surfais
bonne idée alors il ya un truc est très
beau aussi c'est la montre avec un
bracelet en cuir un peu comme un
bracelet de force si tu veux il ya une
bombe oui j'aime bien ça je pense que ça
fait un peu
ouais ça fait quoi pourquoi
sado-maso savent pas danser ça dommage
pour que j'aime pas trop patron t'es pas
trop s m non
c'est pas mauvais
c'est vrai comment le défi
ouais cette prépa clé baffie un cocktail
lui non à 6 7% à 1 il va arriver là il
est il est passionné encore bâtis marge
est encore et encore
on aurait dû faire goûter si ça lui
plaît on appellera le boeuf une belle
fille le baffie assez jolie salle où ma
fille
ça pour une soirée sm tu vois
[Musique]
oui bonsoir
voulez monsieur bâti au quatrième étage
s'il vous plaît
oui celui certes radio qui joue avec la
caf mais tous les joueurs oui bonsoir
l'intervenant tué à petit bateau celui
importé jour là
[Musique]
monsieur baffie asile vous
vous manger gras quand vous voulez une
chaise à porteurs voit pas d'argent je
vous ai temps et ça c'est quoi le tout
mis dedans dans la verdure c'est quoi en
vrai si basique à du basilic fait votre
ami baffie joue avec est très joueur du
13 juin renater bon je dirais même qu
est un sale gosse
monsieur
ces genres et
épauler lot volé 20 la part gaston la
personne qui veut ça tia
[Musique]
koné gilou ces trois formations aulas
chine
alors il ya quoi dans le bâti et de la
pomme et de la pomme a comme dans la
pomme comme dans les tontons flingueurs
j'ai connu une polonaise campagne au
petit déjeuner le feu ça rend aveugle à
vous faire attention
je suis allé au bistrot en bas de chez
moi l'autre jour et le le patron du
bistrot il y avait son frère de sa
belle-soeur qui arrivait de deux
d'auvergne et ils m'ont dit on va voir
la pièce de laurent baffie c'est à dire
que tu fais partie maintenant comme des
choix de pièces quand les gens viennent
à paris les provinces au viennent à
paris tu es comme
il ya la pièce de laurent ruquier il ya
la pièce de l'emmerdeur avec timsit et
berry et toi
mais je crois qu'un pas 50 comme elle
est très drôle maintenant que l'hôtel ça
coûte la peau du cul et que les gens
écoutent cher trop cher oui ça coûte
cher ça coûte 40 42 euros continuant
famille ccc plus cher que disneyland
crash mais ça coûte cher aussi le
théâtre à faire ça que tout le monde
fait des one man on a ça coûte pas cher
le one man show ça y'a pas de décors
n'ya pas de communauté les places sont
vendues le même prix et les placent en
lui le même plaidant cohade man qui
gagnent beaucoup d'argent c'est pour ça
que
ça dure jusqu'à quand la pièce
encore plaçant encore 400 on va finir la
saison on reprend la saison prochaine tu
reprends septembre jusqu'en juin non
jusqu'en juillet
après à la tournée il ya déjà semblable
mon s'est jeté dessus tout le monde tout
toutes les villes veulent la pièce mais
les formidables cette pièce moi je les
ai vus
donc là ce soir les philosophes way avec
ton ami ferry dans la plaie j'adore un
ferry on se connaît pas depuis longtemps
s'est croisé deux fois sur des plateaux
et deux fois au truc contre le cancer
parce que je suis également contre le
cancer c'est contre le cancer déjà tu es
contre le sida contre le cancer et la
mononucléose non le rhume encore ça va
mais après je suis dès mi temps
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui bonsoir c'est lui qui marie caroline
ferry je vous en prie au quatrième étage
merci
[Musique]
je les accueillir à passer par m
vient maintenant alors je me forge de
laguiole un jonathan joubert
[Musique]
4e
oui ces mesures décentes à
trianon messieurs
qui monte
[Musique]
terrible
fallu cela
comment mes valeurs 10 on y va très bien
ça va pas vers rend le bourhis
lâchez-vous soir et a fait un tabac
redemandant grand tabac quand ça toi
parce que ouais sinon
difficile à faire le père personnes le
soir même que le livre existe
il souvent le livre blanc oui tu es
numéro 3 non
je ne sais pas cette semaine 2 non
vraiment je la classerais
l'émission où on prend vraiment des
bouquins c'est la tienne on les a tous
les avants les quatre livres qui sont en
tête
du hit parade des livres ces quatre
livres qu'on fait tout le monde en parle
c'est toi ouais c'est bernard henri lévy
c'est giesbert et c'est zemmour l4
chasser l'intrus avec 3 bons livres
et qu'est ce tu fais toi là ont
maintenant la sérieusement
j'ai monté une boîte effets de la déco
ah ouais ouais je vais pas de cinéma
noms du cinéma non moins
il veut pas sinon j'ai tout se passait
bien mais je serais
moi et non j'avais fait j'avais tourné
dans un film c'est un alt et pas sur le
moment oui c'est ça une ans j'avais fait
la partie inférieure du million de noms
venus donc être un truc est passé
totalement inaperçu un petit film on
écoute c'était un film quelques grenades
à celle d'un copain et tu jouais le rôle
d'une d'une c'est ça oui c'est du
cinéma oui non non c'était un rôle de
composition ça te dirait pas oui c'est
un problème
je la dirai donc ça avait commencé en
fait avant que je ne sois ministre et la
grèce avait continué pendant que j'étais
ministre est donc le truc que tu es
sorti dans la presse disant que marie
caroline faisait des films x était la
plus jeune femme de ministre de la vème
république
sous la ivème c'était danielle
mitterrand ah oui j'ai déjà très âgé de
27 ans ouais j'avais 27 ans 27 ans alors
ils s'en souviennent encore ministère
marais ça a marqué les esprits au moment
du vote alors quitte à laisser un
souvenir dans la république eh oui tu
t'es bien sûr c'est le seul que j'ai
laissé mes non mais attends blague à
part ce qui s'est passé au au ministère
parce qu'il ya eu l'histoire du petit
chien mon beau père un jour le bichon
ce n'était pas un riche en vtt prétend
qu'il ya ait un jour mon beau père qui
est assez farceur est arrivé avec un
petit chien mais tu sais comme c'est
mignon les tout petits chiens des
petites choses comme ça qu'a vais je pas
15 jours ou trois semaines et il a
offert aux deux petites est évidemment
impossible de le rendre après une fois
qu'elles ont vu c'est vrai on est alors
qu'il y avait des travaux au ministère
le chien passait de la résidence a en
effet à la salle de la grande salle
condorcet on a les réunions de recteur
et c'est ce qui s'est pas tarie caroline
qui étaient au milieu de la salle mais
c'était le petit chien qui était au
milieu et tous les recteurs des
universités et au milieu il ya des
réunions de recteur tu as tous les
recteurs donc ils sont une trentaine et
tu as tous les directeurs
d'administration centrale qui sont
généralement quand même des gens assez
série faut bien dire mais le petit chien
au milieu et donc à mes collaborateurs
du cabinet qui qui est elle passée sous
la table pour aller rattraper le petit
chien opulence avait très mauvais effet
mais on remettait à la résidence et ce
qui convenait à chaque fois parce que
les pommes rissolées berne pineau wade
groupe i mais il resté célèbre le sien
avait vraiment à l'époque c'était luc
ferry qui était qui était ministre merci
enfin si tu veux plus que c'est qu'un
jour il l'a vu en garde et il va sur le
marché il ya une femme qu'il arrête en
étant mais sélectionnerait karine ferri
qu'est ce qu'il fait avec vous des papas
lui dit je suis grand père je mets en
garde
il y avait ça il est le chien le débat
rési aussi serré que tu avais des bas
résilles quand des théories non non
c'est pas le même qu'aujourd'hui tu vois
qu'ils sont en réseau
je suis pas obligé d'aimer tout d'eau
une
règle et sexy pour une femme de ministre
à rien na waie
corinne terme n est pas mal
en forme de côté aussi en dix ans
revenir et d'autres très très bien c'est
vrai je les croisais dans un hôtel au
bord de la mer
l'été dernier j'ai trouvé très bien une
qui est brunch et non pas des mots comme
ça mais de chirac
je construis 60 ans une visible
les bas résilles avec miley la salle de
gym ont dit que la salle de gym c'est
vrai ça me veux tu que ce soit vrai
attend c'est inimaginable un bureau
salle de gym en salle en sous-sol au
ministère qui servait à l'association
d'entre aide à prendre des cours de
peinture et moi j'ai dit dans cette
salle on peut mettre la peinture
ailleurs ce que la peinture n'a pas
besoin d'autant d'espacé et je fais une
salle qu'on donne à l'association
entraide et qui sert aux 3500 personnes
qui travaillent sur le site du service
de la rue de grenelle donc la salle de
sport mais jamais mis les pieds mais
elle sait maintenant si tu vois tu payes
5 euros à l'année tu peux aller faire du
sport pour tous le monde sait que j'ai
en fait je sais quoi c'est le symbole
marie antoinette oui
c'est à dire que cette pauvre marconne
j'ai beaucoup étudié cette époque de
l'histoire de france on couvre que
j'aime beaucoup et il est bon maintenant
ça va mieux marie antoinette avait
réhabilité mais pendant des années et
des siècles ont expliqué que des
colonnes fait que les truites étaient
détruits qui était complètement fou
il ya eu l'histoire quand vous êtes
arrivé c'est vrai que tu as été surprise
par la décoration et si l'appartement
quand même c'est un
bon jour des études ça veut dire qu'il
ya des dégâts très technique et il
n'était pas habitable mais tu sais ce
que j'ai fait tout le monde avait été là
la décoration de jacques lambert a dû
tomber en désuétude c'était l'horreur ce
truc est donc il fallait il fallut
habitants qui avaient des il y avait un
dégât des eaux et donc il n'était pas
été vaccinés depuis 15 ans et donc la
réhabilitation était prévu et ça ça
pleurait parce que les ministres avaient
pas habiter dans les minutes qui était
par diaby puis la nuit non parce que
normalement si tu veux un ministre un
appartement à paris en principe quand il
s'est mis ce normal il appartint et nous
on n'avait pas d'appartement donc on
enfin vous avez demandé d'habiter à la
résidence à nous à tous les ministres
qui avaient pas l'appartement a eu quoi
donc d'habiter dans les résidences quand
il y avait des résidences et la
résidence n'était pas habitable
puisqu'elle était elle était dévastée
quoi donc alors pour une fois je l'avais
prévu le coup j'ai pris une cinquantaine
de photos et quand le type du canard
enchaîné deux nuls
je vais visiter le louvre le truc et du
coup de quoi il nous a lâché là dessus
mais la lettre l italie draps en satin
que vous avez achetés aux frais marais
publica jeu
sa fondation dans l'émission télé
certains raffarin dans l'année adorable
on l'appelle en fait l'entamé
c'est toi qui la gtoi qu'il l'a
conseillé d'être d'être ministre quand
même encore un autre prénom en fait il
m'a posé la question il m'a dit on l'a
appelé il il me dit et si on m'appelle
pour être ministre je suis dit wow on
t'appellera jamais pour être ministre on
va t'appeler pour te demander ce que tu
penses du prochain ministre et il me dit
mais si c'est ça et je dis lui que ça
fait huit ans que tu travailles que tu
es présent du conseil nacelle des
programmes ça fait huit ans que tu
t'adresses à l'asus qui pour la peur
fait le exactement pour un philosophe et
le met les mains dans le cambouis si tu
n'es pas les mains dans le cambouis
après tant par le plus quand on me
propose la chose
si tu m'avais dit non tu vois je n'y
serais jamais allé si ces vilains qui
m'avait appelé et je me souviens très
bien s'il avait laissé un message dans
sa valise mois et bien commun qu'est
mois très chargé non mais vraiment tu
peux mon avis doit être occupée mais
il ne nous avait il m'avait laissé un
message le vendredi soir est donc la
nomination du gouvernement étaient en
couple se faisait par le week end on
savait que mardi le gouvernement devait
être nommée et j'avais pas rappelé il
m'a laissé trois messages gpara puis
tellement j'avais les jetons parce que
je me disais mais attends c'est possible
ils sont tellement fou ils peuvent le
demander et on sait jamais être moi ça
devait arriver ils sont tellement vous
peuvent me demander mon libraire et
ministre interposés c'est le lundi matin
que deux mini car rappelez et que là
j'ai décroché attendait déjà réparé les
âmes alcaline qui m'avait dumas tenté
par tous comme d'habitude il faut
remédier à l'autre ça ils vont nous
laisser justice conçu pour savoir si
vous m'aimez darcos ou où je sais pas
qui est donc 2000 me dit bon ben voilà
on va proposer des trains d'être un
ministre et tout ça avec les cats
ministère puisqu'il y avait la recherche
les ducs les universités et la jeunesse
et moi je vous dis mais attends je pète
secrétaire d'état parce qu'on a bien
fait je croyais naïvement qu'on pouvait
faire quelque chose quand on a été
ministre mais c'est à dire vrai non plus
et donc je bossais et donc
à cause de toi je lui met un cause un
ministère comme l'éducation que tu as
forcément des âgées parce que quand il
ya 12 millions et demi d'élèves en
france il ya huit cent mille professeurs
et donc tu as toute la france en vérité
et donc forcément chaque jour il ya une
catastrophe si un élève suicidé il ya un
type qui s'est tuée il ya un inspecteur
d'académie qui a eu un accident de
voiture et on croit qu'on a du pouvoir
enfin on va pas rentrer nos discussions
serrées mais c'est très intéressant
parce que les ministres s'imaginent
qu'ils ont du pouvoir parce que on a du
pouvoir sur une centaine 200 300
personnes autour de soi parce que tu
peux par exemple nommé un recteur ou le
dénommé du jour au lendemain c'est quand
même des postes très importants avec des
voitures de fonction des appartements
avec des responsabilités très grande
avec beaucoup d'emmerdés moi aussi les
recteurs ils font un métier forme il a
été très difficile et donc tu as du
pouvoir sur les gens qui t'entourent
mais sur le cours des choses c'est un
autre une autre affaire faire en sorte
que les mômes apprennent vraiment à lire
l'ocp ça tu as très peu de pouvoir
là-dessus mais dénommé ou nommer
quelqu'un ça donne évidemment un
sentiment bien vous et son musée
location simple un job ariste quand vous
voulez mais qui reste jamais très
longtemps surtout quand on est pédophile
vous êtes que lui comment tous les deux
alain un jour les frères bogdanoff bt en
vacances ils squattaient chez les
parents de marie caroline a
dans le sud ouest là où ils ont une
maison et donc ils squattaient là et
moi j'étais tout seul à ce moment là
j'étais entre entre deux eaux emprunt de
mariner et donc il ya les bogda qui
m'appelle en me disant mauvaise en
disant écoute et on est dans une maison
incroyable absolument génial c'est
magnifique on est au bord de l'eau il ya
quatre nanas absolument sublime il faut
que tu viennes céline bak dan av et
alors tu attends je dis vous êtes
toujours comme ça mais c'est pas vous
qu'un vite et moi je je viens pas dans
des endroits où c'est pas le maître de
maison qui m'a vite j'ai gardé un peu
d'éducation de fabre et donc je dis non
je dis non trois fois quatre fois puis
un jour je reçois un coup de fil du père
de marie caroline gens qui dit écoutez
bon les beaux gars vous ont invité mais
en fait c'est moi qui vous invite on
serait ravis que vous veniez que sa
fille est mariée
quatre mariées à la région de luzon pour
deux ans moi je vois déjà 55 balais
volants et alors elle tenait l'un des
restaurants de l'île de ré un métier de
chien jusqu'à 3 heures du matin tous les
jours 7 heures du matin à 3h du matin à
l'endroit 2 et je déboule là dedans je
tombe sur marc ollivier quand même c'est
pas un monstre et donc
tu étais content
attendu photographier les crapules
toi je renverse sac là il y en a dix a
pas d'ascenseur du premier soir là il ya
deux souris 375 points en plus c'est
vrai il est gras pour le sahara m tout
ça c'est des combos
faut boycotter les lakers de grenouilles
bon super bon mois il faut jamais
toucher à savoir pourquoi parce qu'ils
prennent les grenouilles the les pattes
et il laisse les lego le légaliser dans
un coin vraiment faut pas toucher à ça
or on n'a pas que tu vois ça bonjour
dénoncer tous leurs espoirs en vous
faites ça chez vous quelle bande
d'enculés au bristol
oui bonsoir à lewis et v sont chauds
acquis le fameux duo au quatrième si
vous voulez
à
c'est
4e
tout indique qu'il faut c'est des larmes
j'ai reçu
c'est la namibie ou
comment ça va soir à chaumont soir
mais moins bon manteau
merci merci c'est simple j'entends des
bruits à 4,8
millions
banks était prévu ils ont failli la
maison celui maintenant j'ai pas
en mois du lat fille et vous êtes un peu
on a du mal déjà moi ça fait une paye
que je t'ai pas vu toi tu veux parler à
rhodes tourné au jerusalem and à la fois
que je t'ai vu c'était donc qui à
presque 9 10 mois c'est ça et alors je
suis je crois que les parisiens
je n'arrive sans compter les miens et
mais sans compter la chaux-de-fonds
impression de juin
voilà donc j'ai fait au jerusalem tient
rillettes de thon c'est moi c'est cacher
séquelles chez atrabile à rillettes de
thon et cacher
ça s'est bien passé on dirait
je compte c'est ce que j'ai fait le plus
difficile
je fais du cinéma je suis très heureux
du chef canton à rhodes tourné à rhodes
et que je tourne à jérusalem est tu peux
j'ai tourné à
liverpool où on a reconstitué new york
avec les vieilles rues en brique est
tous là
on a eu 1 milliard de problèmes
financiers qu'on a résolues on a
c'était bien ça coûtait cher à la sortie
le film coût de 20 millions
d'euros oui quand même c'est l'argent
c'est pas tout à fait rien c'est un gros
film s'avoue film
allez avoue valencian à
jérusalem non mais lui a tant il est
numéro deux des ventes ça va pour les
écoutes ça fait dix ans qu'on fait
l'émission c'est la première fois que je
vois un mec parler de philosophie et il
a été brillant brillant accessible et
c'est rarissime on n'a pas triché dire
qu'on a commencé au stoïcien on a fini à
derrida cedar n'a pas triché affirmant
l'histoire la philo en 20 minutes s'est
passé dans l es et tu peux en vivre
dans toute cette histoire c'est que
l'audience n'a pas baissé c'est une
émission de bot à 28,8 ou à 29,2 toi bon
donc l'audience a pas baissé et lui dès
la semaine suivante une maman des 3800
points c'est à dire que si tu veux ça
c'est vraiment le service public dense
que saad mieux quoi faire que on aurait
pu penser que les gens a pas du tout
hésité moi je pense que les gens dont tu
leur expliques clairement les choses ils
sont d'accord c'était la première
interview au quelqu'un value boca
vraiment qu'au bout de la table suivi le
même avis mais c'est parce que c'est
vrai que j'ai dit en mettant ça aide
incroyable parce que la pose des vraies
questions et tu dis voilà comme met
alors à ce moment-là qu'est ce qui se
passait tout ce que tu as vraiment envie
de raconter
donc moi j'avais envie de le raconter
comme je voyais qu'il y avait des gens
autour de la table qui étaient pas tous
agrégé de philo j'avais envie que ça
passe et c'est passé magali dans ce sens
sont mal est un génie elle m'a dit elle
m'a dit c'est un c'est un génie absolu
donc j'ai essayé de la calmer je n'ai vu
l'écart est d'ailleurs j'aurais pu tirer
le rideau s'est déjà bien enfin je suis
au téléphone c'était tu étais dans la
vologne j'étais à lépanges sur vologne
oui
jérôme béglé il en est allé lui est
moins sur les lieux deux de l'assassinât
les lieux du crime rien voilà et c'était
assez c'est étonnant et c'est solennelle
bizarrement je m'attendais pas un truc
pareil c'est drôle est ce qu'il ya des
gens qui viennent il ya des touristes
qui viennent alors il parait qu'il ya
des gens qui viennent régulièrement
comme un sac et drôle parce que les
planches sait rien sur le petit grégory
oui c'est à dire qu'en fait une nouvelle
collection chez grasset jacques on
demande à des écrivains de faire des
livres sur des faits divers et il a
choisi le petit grégory jeu s'appelle
comment s'appelle l'enfant docteur à
bord 9 en octobre et en fait c'est une
idée géniale qui a eu grâce et mafate
c'est en même temps c'est ça s'inscrit
dans une tradition parce que finalement
le rouge et noir c'est un fait divers de
sang froid c'est un fait divers c'est un
bon donc donc
c'est très bonne idée ils n'ont pas eu
de mal à trouver dix écrivains pour la
collection ça c'est clair et c'est vrai
que moi j'ai eu envie de cette histoire
tout de suite parce que voilà je me suis
très bien quand ça s'est passé je me
suis exactement où j'étais et puis voilà
ça ça frappe la mémoire collective c'est
parce que l'enfant mort c'est toujours
un tabou quoi c'est quelque chose de
terrible et moi ce qui m'intéressait
c'était plus d'ailleurs le sait - faits
divers que le rapport de la mère à
l'enfant mort c'est un truc que j'ai
déjà exploré explorer dans d'autres
livres mais mais j'essaie d'imaginer
comment tu es la mère d'un enfant mort
et pire comment tu es la mère d'un
enfant assassiné le fait divers n'a
toujours pas été éclaircis mais c'est ça
la force de se déverser que 20 ans après
22 ans va être presque 22 ans après tu
sais pas et tu seras jamais c'est que tu
es dans un truc où à part si la
confession sur un lit de main sur
l'assassin se dénonce tu seras jamais
parce que même les dernières choses qui
ayant eu lieu à quelques années des
tests adn sur les timbres du corbeau
respect de corbeau qui a envoyé des
lettres etc bref ils ont fait vingt
quinze ans après des expertises adn sur
l'axé pas utilisable s'est passé ça et
on expliquer que c'est pas possible du
moins cool à l'instruction est close
et que le fait divers c'est la défaite
du romancier cercle quand on est
romancier le fait divers tout d'un coup
c'est le sait quand le réel est plus
fort que la fiction cirque anticipa
c'est un truc que toi romancier t'aurais
pas osé imaginer ou si tu oses l'imaginé
tu oses pas l'écrire et tout d'un coup
ça s'est produit c'est ça ça a eu lieu
cette histoire là donc c'est un truc
assez bons il y avait un travail d
enquête phénoménal vous voulez faire
revenir tout le dossier
ça c'est un truc assez drôlement
travaillé ses recettes
il faut lire ça faut dire ça de doc
non mais enfin quand je dis ça ça
pourrait être le double mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que moi j'ai jamais
absolument est un romancier j'invente
tout donc j'ai pas besoin de voir des
documents sur balles hélas pour la fin
de ma vie a fallu que j'ai ça de
documents à lire et ce qui est drôle
c'est que moi j'avais demandé en plus à
avoir ça c'est intéressant la presse de
l'époque il ya des livres qui sont être
extradé dans les dix ans de recul tout
est truqué la presse absolument
effrayant parce que tu vois surtout que
les gens disent n'importe quoi c'est
dire que la presse raconte absolument
interdit tout et le contraire de tout
les choses sont dix sont dit au présent
elle devrait être au conditionnel et
c'est pas bon et les des gens sont jetés
en pâture des secret d'instruction est
bafoué le juge change de conviction et
c'est tout ça est suivi par les médias
au fur et à mesure le juge s'est
vachement intéressant au final
l'évolution est
intéressant avec cette phrase
vertigineuse que qu'il prononce le juge
lambert quand il quand il inculpe à
l'époque on disait inculpé pas mettre en
examen quand ils inculquent christine
villemin donc la mer c'est la cote il ya
ce basculement qui se produit bien quand
même cirque au début quand il est en
forme mais évidemment c'est la mer
supplicié elle a tout pour elle bon
voilà les gens se disent c'est horrible
pas ce qui lui arrive la chose la pire
qui puisse arriver mer par un enfant aux
yeux donc elle a hélas pour elle la
sympathie du monde de cette femme là et
puis petit à petit il est sûr de
basculement le tribunal de l'opinion se
met en branle et rien qu'on se dit c'est
tel que c'est peut-être elle qui a tué
l'enfant et donc elle devient la mère
présumée infanticide et le joaillier
marguerite duras forcément suez mais un
attique manif à 2
071 terrible is merveille non mais quel
talent mais j'ai trouvé ça extrêmement
choquant - ce oui parce qu'elle dit que
la mère est coupable c'est ce que moi je
suis comme toi je suis j'ai été choqué
par cet article la part d'igs duras et
moi je défends en exactement la thèse
inverse je défends
en examen en exergue ça parce qu'elle
dit un truc non mais le dit qu'il a
truqué très intéressant c'est elle dit
ce crime est insondable plus on se
rapproche et plus nous échappe et ça
c'est vrai parce que moi qui ai beaucoup
travaillé dessus jeu il me semble que je
le connais moins maintenant que j'ai
beaucoup travaillé dessus mais ce qui
est terrible c'est que l dans l'article
de libé en juillet 85 en plus aux pires
moments c'est un moment la mer est
inculpé alors je reviens juste lorsque
j'étais sur le juge ça qu'on le juge un
cul plat vers l'apologie de
l'infanticide est pour essayer oui mais
ça mais quand il inculpe la mer le juge
lambert il dit cette phrase effrayante
il dit tant pis je me lance
tandis que moi je voulais vraiment faire
un roman et donc j'ai fait un truc par
exemple dans le roman c'est que j'essaie
de trouver la voix de christine villemin
j'essaie de comprendre qui elle est moi
ce qui m'intéresse encore une fois c'est
elle donc je me dis comment elles
traversent ça parce que moi je crois
fondamentalement à son innocence et et
je me dis comment elle fait pour pas se
tirer une balle cette femme là parce
qu'elle a perdu son fils dans des
conditions absolument atroce et tout le
monde enfin une grande partie des gens
pensent qu'elle est coupable comment
elle tient le choc et je suis un peu
fleur bleue je me dis elle tient le choc
parce que c'est une femme amoureuse jeu
quand même mine de rien 20 20 ans après
elle est toujours mal en ce sens qu ils
ont trois enfants
oui bonsoir bonsoir tester leur mort
bonsoir manuel angot au quatrième s'il
vous plaît
je ne sais pas on verra bien on verra
bien
[Musique]
le nom
m
mais
donc ça n'a ses vieux bonsoir
cd
oui
crise est passée par là
[Musique]
bonsoir
voilà
bonsoir on chante et
on passe à table non
moi je me laver les mains oui si mon
chéri nosophobie
thierry
nosophobie c'est quoi la peur des
microbes des maladies
s'est tu et voilà
mais je suis content de vous connaître
parce qu'en fait vous avez travaillé
balance yaga et oui et pour moi balance
agacé comme les facel vega quoi c'est
vraiment à s'accorder des mots comme ça
quoi c'est juste le mot s'offusque je
connais pas c'est dommage que le ps ait
pas il était comment ce qui est étonnant
c'est étonnant aujourd'hui c'est
l'actualité de balenciaga c'est cela qui
tique des stupéfiants tout le monde se
réclame mais peu l'ont connu
très peu ont travaillé auprès de lui
je suis extrêmement
ému y toucher et encore aujourd'hui
chaque fois que je parle de l'île où
chaque fois que je prenais un bout de
toile
c'est à lui que je pensais parce qu'il a
installée véritablement toute la
modernité dans ce métier il était et est
d'origine espagnole avait pas amants et
espagnol elite basque masque espagnols
décédés san sébastian exactement son
petit pêcheur dans un petit village qui
s'appelle guitare bien là où il est
enterré d'ailleurs celle du cimetière
marin très beau splendide et
j'étais de temps à terme en tailleur et
ce qui était beau aussi de l'église
était préparé pour une fête religieuse
c'est à dire qu' il y avait une fête
c'est pas triste du tout et c'est ce qui
m'a fait dire que va lancer avec
annonçant a réussi sa vie il a réussi sa
mort
il apporter véritablement non seulement
la modernité la rigueur la technique
d'ailleurs mademoiselle chanel disaient
tous ces couturiers sont des
dessinateurs yaka couturier sebha 26,1
ya une chose qui m'intéresse chez vous
c'est que moi ma première femme son
grand père était venu d'italie disent
allez d'italie et lui vous vous êtes à
le décaler pas vieilli sans alex en
provence puis il est allé à avignon il a
créé une maison de couture à avignon
mais non mais oui je servais cazalis non
il a créé une maison de couture elle
même à ma mère s'appelait car ces
petites maisons de couture à avignon
incroya après sa fille et donc mon ex
belle-mère a repris la faire et ma
première femme et sa soeur faisait des
défilés pour leur mère et leur
grand-père c'est comme ça tous alain
vignon tout ça en avignon à la fin des
années 60 début des 70 et c'est comme ça
que je les ai connus c'est à dire
c'était vraiment les stars c'est
incroyable deux frangines et moi j'en ai
épousé une je suis resté dix ans avec 4
et mon père était tout d'abord il est
parti pour raisons politiques c'est un
anti fasciste notoire il a vu l'activité
politique extrêmement importante à aix
tout en travaillant en extérieur pour
ans madame 17 ans à l'époque et dans son
activité politique
ils avaient ils vu
il m'a appris à coudre enfin à 6 ans je
sais moi qu'il étaye la machine à coudre
oui c'était le cadeau du samedi soir il
fallait nettoyer et huiler la machine à
coups bas et comme tous les préventions
évidemment ex on étouffe évidence cette
époque cette vague là elle comptait
trente mille habitants dormaient
complètement
avignon était déjà un peu plus vivant
mais je n'ai aucun intérêt de lire les
lignes ont
donc à nous de pareils tous faisait rage
à réparer voilà 22 ans voilà c est avec
avec à un pantalon et de chemises de
tous ne connaissant pas
on
oui bon choix sa belle
quatrième s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
je pense à
mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir moi
bonjour ça va très très bien
qu'est ce que tu as fait tes cheveux là
encore dans une soupe est là je vous
s'il avait les cheveux là tout à l'heure
ah oui
c'est vrai tu veux que j'aille me
pour vous il est très bien c'est pas
pire que les joueuses et les joueurs à
qui
je faisais pas si belle thierry qui peut
m'expliquer peut me dire qui est 6ème si
ben est une musicienne qui fait de la
musique brésilienne qui m'a choqué venu
ici une fois qui m'a complètement
envoûté et depuis je ne cesse d'avoir
envie de la revoir et c'est ce soir
d'accord les deux mais vous êtes
brésilienne brasilia dans mes déchets je
suis fait ma christine alors je te vois
plus la main coûte parce que j'ai crié
c'est pour ça que je vous ai pu alors là
c'est est-ce que tu reviens là
quand vous l'invitez qu'elle fermait ont
été invités que jean c'est la cliente du
chiac elle est formidable
mais c'est quand alors c'est ça fait
huit ans je publie un livre par an j'ai
besoin de vacances pas du tout
d'écriture parce qu'au fond c'est des
moments bénis rêver on est seul entre
bing chez soi c'est génial romaric de
blida
rapporte de l'argent
mais c'est cesser mes vacances lancement
du crime oui pourquoi recommencer je
peux pas dire c'est le finisseur
d'ailleurs ça va être plus chaud que le
terne et si j'en parle ça plombe la
sorte
c'est certes un peu plus chaud mais pas
très
des trucs un peu sec soit tu aimes bien
et c'est tout d'ailleurs c'est pas toi
mais moi je peux pas parler de ce que je
suis en train d'écrire sa suppression
possible j'en parle je vais pas les
crimes et je me disais ça il disait
toujours quand on prête quand je prépare
un film je le raconte pas parce que si
je vous raconte j'ai plus envie de le
faire comme tout le monde le sait à
présent cela et puis on a l'impression
que ça se fait en soi comme comme un
bébé presque ça je m'en
veux nommer jacob question tout terrain
et bien non il ya aussi un truc de
superstition c'est ya aussi et un petit
transistor wegmann ger demande si c'est
bon c'est bon signe
tu sais un jour avec qu'igor on était
dans un bain justement dans le
restaurant marie-caroline dont on parle
et rit et jean qui les a présentés
absolument pas je dirais que bravo c'est
quand même pas mal ah c'est pas mal de
temps en temps j'ai pensé et je me dis
que c'est alors que j'ai fait d'amour ça
ne baisse pas d'intensité
il a toujours la même fougue
pour qui recrée à chaque à chaque
instant non mais c'est sait il est
certain que ce jour là on a une grande
inspiration avec jk et puis avec eux
avec
avec amélie également on a décidé de
demander à luc de venir nous rejoindre
sur l'île de ré et voilà la france a
confirmé au pied et en effet tout est
parti de là parce que un instant de la
rencontre entre lieux qui marie caroline
on peut pas dire que ça a été le coup de
foudre tout de suite mais
quelque chose était en train de se faire
voilà et moi j'ai en effet su tout de
suite que il y aurait une promesse qui
devraient très longtemps mais elle n'a
pas été immédiate parce qu'il y avait
quelqu'un d'autre dans la vie de
caroline à ce moment là et que l'udc
était et est revenue comme une antienne
mais là
c'est trop grave non c'est trop grave il
faut vraiment prendre le temps aux 41
min
tit qui
elle était avec jackson car il faut le
dire maintenant
depuis le xviiie siècle il ya deux
grandes traditions qui qui traverse
toute la toute la pensée mondiale on
peut dire en tout cas occidentales mais
mondiale il ya au fond une tradition
spinoziste qui vous invite à c'est celle
qui va jusqu'à nietzsche à vous
réconcilier avec le monde et puis une
tradition qui est plutôt passe par
kanouté marx qui vous invite à
transformer le monde moi j'explique ça à
ma fille très simplement je dis voilà
quand on va plonger à port cros et qu'on
regarde les poissons qu'on met son
masque et ses palmes pour regarder à
l'intérieur de l'eau qui est si
magnifique et où on voit des choses
sublimes on ne plonge pas à port cros
pour transformer le monde on plonge à
port cros pour se réconcilier avec le
monde pour aimer le monde et pour être
en fusion avec lui et les médicaments
donc là on est dans la mort faty on est
dans une doctrine de la réconciliation
avec le monde et pas dans une doctrine
de la transformation du monde en
revanche quand féministe de l'éducation
nationale ou même si tu passes par
hasard à auschwitz pour prendre un
exemple vraiment dramatique tuez pas là
pour aimer le monde si tu peux le
transforme et que le changement est à la
limite une philosophie de la
réconciliation avec le monde à auschwitz
ou au rwanda elle est obscène l'idée de
linosa ou de nietzsche c'est l'idée que
les deux grands mots qui pèse sur la vie
humaine c'est le passé et l'avenir qu'on
est constamment dans la nostalgie du
passé ou dans la culpabilité se réveille
la nuit en quoi je lis je n'aurais pas
dû dire ça et donc on est torturé voilà
on se jette dans le projet on se dit que
parce qu'on va changer marie de femme de
maison de voiture ça va aller mieux et
donc on n'arrive pas à vivre le présent
c'est pour vous dire que ces deux
attitudes philosophiques sont des deux
attitudes qui au lieu de s'opposer comme
s'il y avait deux philosophies à choisir
comme si on devait choisir l'une contre
l'autre s'agissant des attitudes qui
nous traversent en permanence voilà
ce qu'ils acceptent le monde et ceux qui
veulent le transforment ils veulent
essayer de l'accepter et ceux qui se
disent non ce monde est manifestement
inacceptables il faut le transformer ces
gens détestent généralement tu dans
quelle catégorie de ceux qui cherchent à
accepter le monde ou de ceux qui
cherchent se transformer voilà à
transformer le monde doit te transformer
soi-même c'est encore autre chose alors
c'est parce que je me suis transformé
que je souhaiterais transformer le monde
mais tu vois là
mais si tu veux manger le côté de quel
côté tu mets des deux côtés pourquoi
parce que du point de vue scientifique
la science a toujours voulu transformer
le monde elle est là pour ça et là pour
transformer la réalité qui nous entoure
mais du point de vue philosophique je
suis du côté complètement du côté de la
réconciliation pourquoi parce que je je
pense que c'est là que on va au fond des
choses on est dans lé sens si on peut
dire de la réalité alors que quand on
essaie de transformer le monde on est du
côté de la pratique de la praxis de
l'herméneutique enfin tout c'est toutes
ces doctrines qui font que ou même la
science la recherche on n'est pas dans
l'essence même des choses les vrais
moments de grâce dans l'existence les
vrais moments de sérénité et de bonheur
si ça existe c'est lé moment dans
lesquels on est plutôt dans la
réconciliation avec le monde que dans la
transformation clés les vrais morts et
leurs tout le monde les connaît ça peut
être un petit apéritif que tu prends ce
soir sur la terrasse devant la mer ou
sur ton bateau je sais pas où à la
campagne dans ton château là bas dans le
jet ou d'un seul coup tu es heureux
parce que avoir un boulot avoir un
château s'est compliquée la télé au
matin et parce que
si tu voyais le château et mais parce
que tu tues d'un seul coup tu te
retrouves en harmonie avec le monde est
débarrassé du souci de le transformer
donc c'est quand même les vrais moments
de bonheur si je puis le système s'est
quand même plutôt ça le moment où on a
l'impression que ça y est on est en
harmonie avec les gens directement et
qu'on n'a pas on n'est pas dans le côté
laborieux du mec qui veut transformer
les choses en permanence et qui ennuie
tout le monde avec sir adonis et toi
philippe asnard mais c'est pas moi je me
dis que dès lors que je suis romancier
ça veut dire que je dois avoir un
problème est que réelle tu vois quand
tout cas j'aurai un problème avec le
monde tel qu'il est parce que donc je ne
j'ai l'impression de me citer plutôt du
côté la transformation du monde par
essence parce que je me dis c'est voilà
ce que j'ai sous les yeux ne me convient
pas j'ai envie d'imaginer autre chose de
faire autre chose disons que moi j'ai un
tendance est vaguement pessimiste donc
je me dis j'ai envie de transformer le
monde mais je crois je vais pas y
arriver
je reste avec l'idée que ça avait quand
même un tout petit peu dur et que et
donc à la fin il est toujours chez moi
une part de résignation extrêmement
forte c'est de se dire tout ça
finalement n'aura pas servi à grand
chose alors moi je suis d'accord et tout
ce qui vient d'être dit contrairement à
rossi quant à moi je vais changer le
monde et je pense que je vais
sauver le monde déjà en tout cas j'ai
déjà changé ma vie lors et plus les
années passent et dans mon métier
artistique j'ai une conscience aiguë de
la responsabilité alors ça peut paraître
bizarre de la part d'un comique qui a
débuté en disant des horreurs à tout le
monde mais immédiat un retour immédiat
je ne comprends pas comment dieudonné
peut assumer la responsabilité de ce qui
fait je comprends pas comment ils
l'assument de mettre ces gamins à
l'école ce que de se les torrents de
haine de quelques doigts se venger ses
gosses j'ai une conscience aiguë ça donc
je fais attention à ça et même dans mes
comédies dans mes histoires j'ai un
petit message qui peut apparaître
simpliste mais qui est positive de
tolérance sont interdits les choses par
exemple totalement tu vois c'est un
scoop totalement et je t'emmerde
[Musique]
en
moi évidemment j'ai en changer le monde
je trouve insupportable donc j'ai levé
trop que la tête qui là ne revient pas
et j'ai envie de changer mais je dois
reconnaître que je ne suis vraiment
heureux en tout cas serein que dans les
moments de réconciliation avec le monde
sait que les autres noms sont démentes
grande souffrance des problèmes voilà
donc interdire les choses on peut être
heureux quand oubliant un petit peu non
c'est exactement ça met en doute
l'importance de la drogue
enfin pour ceux qui ne croient pas en
dieu il ya quand même l'un des
magnifiques théorie du génie qui ont été
inventés pour expliquer que je le génie
comme l'humoriste d'ailleurs mais le
grand drame elle attend lui attend une
extraordinaire lors même schori la 10e
30 ans figure ans je ne le trouve génial
chez toi mais les fulgurances laurentais
dans sa nouvelle forme de surcroît
simple la différence entre les
fulgurances de du nul est fulgurant du
mec qui est génial c'est que les
fulgurances du titre que génial elles
font sens commun c'est à tout le monde
rigole où tout le monde m hees a cette
capacité à tirer de soi sans qu'on sache
absolument douceur bien le truc où
savidan sais pas d'où ça vient mais que
ça fasse sens commun pour tout le monde
ça c'est le grand talent de l'humoriste
et le grand talent du génie et si tu lis
pour moi le plus grand livre sur le
sujet c'est un livre de cannes qui
s'appelle la critique de la faculté de
juger où il fait une comparaison terme à
terme entre l'humoriste et l'artiste et
le génial car je n'étais rien n'ont
aucun doute eu accès à la suite les
qu'ancien emmanuel et pour moi les vrais
humoristes alors ça
ça devrait à mon avis est intéressé
c'est pas ce qu'ils racontent des
histoires ou qui ont préparé un scénario
toi qui ont alors il ya des types
formidable tu vois gad elmaleh est pas
tant les trucs sont écrits ou raymond
devos voit ses écrits mais le type qui
est capable c'est ok élevé comme ça de
sortir une blague qui d'un seul coup
férir tout le public ça c'est le coup de
génie parce que j'ai une suite c'est
l'horreur moi je les observe tiens que
l'on est normal
c'est le meilleur je dis toujours leur
hausse et le rain man de la vanne dire
qu'en fait il est assez autistes dans la
vie tout ça et il est sur un plateau et
d'un seul coup il va te dire le truc
mais du tac au tac je suis pas voilà que
tout chien la vachette je cherche pas
bien sûr alors jeter ses cartes et
financier smic risque et comment il fait
alors je t'explique comment cette écoute
et une arme blanche sur facebook tu dis
quelque chose dans la première demie
seconde il scanne toutes les vannes
qu'il en réserve en une demi seconde il
passe tout temps s'il n'a pas la bonne
vanne dans la deuxième demi seconde il
en trouve une voilà c'est ça
ou pas ça arrive ça arrive à trouver
quand même s'ils atterrissent le trouve
très souvent je regardais mission chez
moi je n'y ai je dit comment je n'ai je
pu ne pas dire ça c'est souvent ce qui
fait dans tout le monde en parle c'est
d'ailleurs il est le seul à pouvoir le
faire parce que moi je n'en connais pas
beaucoup d'autres nettement si demain il
passe sous un camion va être très en
vendée
avec cette tournée mission à leader
vaduz
j'adore ce dîner
avec elle est géniale et tout à coup il
arrive il pleut il arrive qu'à lui une
voiture qui bloque le taxi il ya trois
mecs qui descendent nouba masqué issor
khl le chauffeur taxi hippie l'homme
avait arrêté arrêté ils prennent le mec
il lui tape dessus il prête à ça que
j'ai arrêté arrêté fait le rab à ce mot
arrive une voiture de flics ou la
voiture les mecs se tape sur la censure
sur les voyous et huit tables et le milf
et laurent beauvais arrêté arrêté le
chef de la brigade les flics vient vers
le rabbin élie fait et le ram avait
arrêté arrêté
le chef lui mais calmez vous ça y est
arrêté arrêté mais calmez vous c'est
fini d'en arrêter le compteur
là le ton senti qu il existe puissance
moins 43 secondes c'est vrai au moment
de plan
mais on tient il ya cinq ans et c'est
celle entendue temps quand on voit ce
qu'est ce que c'est que ça eh bien c'est
le moment où l'univers apparaît sous sa
forme physique tu vois imagine que
l'univers est un cône comme ça à bondy
l'heure nous sommes dans si tu veux le
voilà tiens voilà ça c'est l'univers un
beau coup nous sommes quelque part ici
on va aller jusqu'au sommet du council a
jusque là qui aident à 10 puissance
moins 43 secondes le film la belle de
filtres voilà toute la partie rouge
toute la partie rouge c'est la partie
énergétique c'est à dire que c'est la
partie matérielle de l'univers dans
lequel nous sommes et qu'est ce que le
temps c'est le temps c'est tout
simplement comment dire la
transformation de l'univers par
l'énergie maintenant ici il y a le temps
de planck discussions devant 43 secondes
hélas toutes les parties blanches là
c'est un monde sans énergie qui est un
monde où le chant ce mélange 2 temps
réel ce mélange autant imaginaire et à 0
il ya que de l'information pure
autrement dit ce qu'on dise j'ai terminé
tout comme chaque être a dit chez chaque
être humain chaque être vivant est posée
précédé par un code génétique sa départ
une information l'univers tout entier
est précédée par une information et
voila voila c'est tout c'est pas
compliqué emmanuel
meirieu ton grand père il ils veulent
réfléchir et par ici ni le vieux avec
tout ce bordel que ta future sur les
murs de nos vieux clichés ils veulent de
planque avec chéri l'argent dans des
malles en mai le lieu mais non c'est pas
ça c'est bien pire
c'est bien pire son grand père je les
connais moi c'était quelqu'un
est bien s'ils venaient et si vous voyez
aujourd'hui ni le lieu où l'heure qu'il
est il le foot est en effet seulement
almeida
haye
eh
oui
et
alors là mais la
base est à la portée
on
entre là
la porte à porte et appauvrit na
li na
à la pause et n'a voté là
à la porte
[Applaudissements]
bravo
[Musique]
mon coeur qu'il faut s'aimer commun
donc et bosser mingoua
[Musique]
montréal qui vaut samia kg
dunkerque ils vont s'aimer doma
mon gars qui vous saignent assista
donc elle qui est passée mais son âme
[Musique]
donc évoqué mes côtés
non car l'eau qui vaut son diplôme
je ne comprenais pas pourquoi tu parles
se tordre et la gueule
sur l'époque mais maintenant j'ai
cambrai on sait pas que c'est les comics
en fait
vu pour le mur de planck
un jour vous êtes un confrère
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux